alright Billy Corbin till it in hi Hank
are Cowboys what is the new give us the
new and we're gonna get right into it
we're not gonna go right into it I want
to go into other stuff before that but
go ahead really hey Billy Joe just go do
it yeah 6,000 bucks you buy torah
portion for my bar mitzvah what am I
gonna go and do ah
hey it's Jimmy Fallon we're at a time we
need funny we were just talking sell
what's talking about James Woods and how
it's not okay to like James Woods on
Twitter and overtime Mike is it Jesse
Smollett who's obviously the news kid
how you pronounce that
where's the first well gonna start this
podcast by saying this I'm just so
grateful that Jesse has been exonerated
I'm glad justice has been served and
that's what I was gonna say and finally
a black pin and get screwed over by our
just our justice system and found
goddamn time because they because
Chicago politics is not at all corrupt
some say it's the most you're a [ __ ]
liberal stay so I want to hear what you
have to say you [ __ ] left yet cuz
Miami has no issues is what this is what
my Twitter feed looks like after I'm on
Rogen show ya a racist you're looking
live tar Koch's snowflake homo feels
like it's like thanks for listening yeah
Christopher Hitchens one time this one
of those you're obviously a liberal and
he said mmm well I'm actually I take
that and take my defense to that because
I'm actually a socialist and we consider
liberals to be dangerous compromises you
had these three the only thing missing
from from that impersonation I would
know how you do it is the ice from the
whiskey like oh my god just the ice
moving around in the glass I'm miss
Hitchens like his voice right now in
this world would be is like desperately
needed yes but what did you you liberal
samba [ __ ] who probably you cheered
when he was exonerated I don't know what
happen Allah I don't believe that he was
exonerated him more than the president
was just exonerated okay
Oh as own attorney general so I don't it
seems like they struck some kind of plea
deal well did you see the the governor
Chicago came out the police came out
mate mayor yeah and the Marianne was
like this is not justice was not served
yeah it was over the head Rahm Emanuel
was already a man you all have to say
well that's why would it you know Rahm
Emanuel Ari Emanuel who owns WMA yeah
that's just that's his brother oh wow
successful yeah yeah
Oh - great time to hang out over to
Nancy probably a white man in America oh
my god this is a great time well they're
both Jewish so let's not you know let's
not conflate white and Julie what time I
got my Zionist conspiracy meeting I
gotta get to my part out hard out here I
think James you have the picture Jim
Jenkins James on James roll didn't host
TT I don't know what he said a holla see
he posted a picture of Jesse Smollett
with Obama's cuz they say Michelle Obama
because that's why it's above even the
Chicago police cuz one above their head
yeah Michelle Obama called in a favor
and Jesse Jackson I realize how powerful
why does he was so 200 but so Michelle
Obama's former aide there is a whole
text chain an email chain I guess to the
to the assistant to the DA apparently or
something and I some of it I read I
don't know this is what you can play
this are nobody would've thought they
could get away with that this was such a
high-profile case that everybody is is
talking about oh there's a score yeah
yeah the table top set up you can just
go to Twitter and type in James Wood
[Music]
James yeah I was seeing that like I feel
like I did something about the movie the
specialist I don't remember this
terrible movie of 94 sylvester stallone
and i mean come on it's alright oh I
love it because it's like one of these
horrible 90s Miami movies yes shot all
in Miami when Stallone had a house down
there and and I posted like some funny
scenes from it including this James
Woods is really hilariously brilliant in
it all that's right he's the only one
who knows it's a comedy like he's the
only one who was led in on the fact that
the movie was a piece of [ __ ] he's so
good in it and so funny and then people
started and then I realize like James
Woods now is kind of like at this moment
in his career were like you know Michael
Jackson is and like Bill Cosby our
language just for he sounded well yeah
people came down I mean for like this
guy's a lunatic what are you doing why
are you celebrating this man I'm like
I'm not celebrated it but he's a
different type of lunatic like he's not
like a dangerous just conserving right
he's a he's just crazy he's just crazy
it was crazy well is he crazier as he
just is he just conservative he's crazy
he's crazy yeah yeah no I haven't seen
interview in the last 10 years be no no
I don't know yeah but Sally he's hurt
but you're like Jackson no but like but
like but people are treating it like
he's over it's over you can't like him
anymore you can't like his well more and
I don't really know now I think he's
great actor yeah and I suspect by the
way he was always crazy and late now
it's just I think we get older we become
magnified horrible versions of ourselves
or something that happens part of his
talent some guys get the in the head or
fall on the bike guys no I think what
happened was he he's always been a
really really intense actor and a like a
really kind of you're a listen like his
movies are amazing because he's so he's
able to access that emotion so he was
obviously a very emotional guy and I
think he got caught up in this
right-left thing and saw the left as
taking over the country and probably
suffers from that kind of paranoia our
worries like I got a wage a one man
fight here that's what it is is just
crazy like if you falling down so deep
you crazy bro yeah that consumes your
life well let me see what's he got
blackballed in Hollywood apparently I
don't know I think he claims because of
his politics which is not illegitimate
no he's a great actor so he could've
been difficult to work with you giving
craziest Julie drag really you know what
I'm all set it was difficult actually to
work no I never heard yeah I don't know
there was never that rumor he was always
a guy you wanted in your movies well
barely not a star yeah really not
where's the tweet though where's that
tweet you mean that takedown oh there is
what's in your wallet
what's in your oh I see hashtag did he
to have to take you down or something oh
no back it it was it's yeah hashtag
Jesse small Michelle Obama holding the
race car national picture though
yeah there's an actual picture that he
posted why is it not coming up you do it
that one but he had questions questions
here's your answer is just Jessie smell
it with the Obamas you see - there's
some crazy ties with him and though
though well that's not so fair because
the end of the day the guy is probably
he's talented he's probably really fun
she didn't know you and a lot of
celebrities spent time with the Obamas
right and there's the show you don't
know you're dealing with it's like a go
can I don't need Chicago can I know
you're dealing with a [ __ ] but I
would I would call chase want a
celebrity it's all you can call it the
White House in like y'all they're like
Jesse smart from Empire yeah yeah come
on down say no more
it might like there are two cats but
they might like to show also with those
shows sometimes they staged these things
were you gonna have a White House you
mean everybody those pictures don't say
anything is what I'm trying to say those
are those are essentially and that's an
award ceremony or something where she's
and he was a singer I don't [ __ ] know
where they're at events just like what
you'd see so it's family worked for them
right in Chicago there's a ton of ties
there's a lot there's a ton of guys
which one I like they they invited the
Empire staff just cuz their ratings were
killing no no their ties yeah I know
their their deep ties yes it's super I'm
not saying that this wasn't corruption
at the worst level at the highest level
Eve that I believe according to what I
have seen that Michelle Obama did get
her aide to intervene and she's all over
the favor to get the charges dropped
which I don't think helps justice
Millette
definitely helps him he's not going to
prison so this really from day one well
actually the 16 counts are actually so
every time you lie to the cops
that's a count but in fact it's the same
charge right so in fact a good lawyer
would have said look these are 16 counts
but what the cops were so mad he was
giving him a run around so that they
every time you lie to the cops
that would be what's considered
obstruction of justice so that's account
the next count the next count but really
the entire lie a lawyer would say look
there's a whole lie here it's one to one
and usually one count you'd pay fines
and you wouldn't necessarily do jail
time you do something especially
convicted by a jerk usually community
service and a big fine big fine
so his fine was 10
this is the problem with the mayor goes
that doesn't cover a [ __ ] now 30
minutes of the efforts we put in to get
this [ __ ] done that's right I think it's
problematic I think the Cook County
prosecutor I would have to think we did
not want to take the political risk of
like just brushing this high profile
like internationally discussed case
under the rug that doesn't do anybody
any good politically or otherwise I
don't understand I can't imagine it
would be incredibly reckless if if
that's what happened here
but you have to realize that first-time
offender like Kalyn said like they
obviously were were overcharging him
mm-hm and the Cook County prosecutor to
take a look at the case and say this is
this is what we should do here this is
how you that's why they make plea
bargains that's all goes bigger fish to
fry
someone dies like give me three second
things he still should have that still
makes the zero sense that all charges
are dropped it makes zero sense this is
the biggest thing happening in Chicago
right now there are no problems for yeah
yeah I agree with you because actually
I'm not that I'm really not you not
upset about it
well thank you I think you know about it
much before and I I don't really find
myself caring that much about it
no I agree that he got his perspective
and I agree 100 said I just think that
that it does say something about our
justice system I don't like the surprise
that it's crooked you should say it's
like when the college thing came out but
you should still be alarms about it so
in other words what are you gonna do
okay so what you do is you you voiced
your concern look if you don't and
corruption if you have a politician that
can call in a favor that degrades our
justice system that's an idea you can't
just say it's politics you've got to
you've got to go that's outrageous and
obviously one of the frustrating things
is there's not much we can do that's
what I'm gonna say what are you gonna do
well what you do is you voice your
profile page yeah and and because it is
and it's and if we start if we have a
justice system where it becomes an
economy of influence where who you know
gets you off which by the way is the
case in we do have a lot of corruption
but my god if it gets to the point where
we're mexico's and say we're Mexico
you're [ __ ] that's your soup your [ __ ]
spoiler alert
we're [ __ ] yeah oh yeah I can tell you
but no our justice system still works
but does it well let's talk about it you
know that's that's rich and powerful or
above the law
unequivocally correct we used to pretend
like that wasn't the case we used to
have people in power still try absolute
but I do agree that if you're rich and
powerful you have a better chance of
getting off that's never been any
different since the founding of the
Republic however however the rich and
powerful do go to jail event like the
spectre and certain guys do get
convicted as long as Aunt Becky goes to
yeah no we we just sing sing I'm cool we
do have a justice system that still
remains to an extent impartial you had
you look at look at the this whole
college cheating scandal they're in deep
[ __ ] it's it's sucks but you're still
getting arrested you're still you're
still having an answer to charges you
still have to hire a lawyer it's not
like you just just walk away so in that
sense I think bet you don't do any time
oh I don't know if that they even should
I just think what happens is in the
court of public opinion and everything
else you're dealing with a lot of [ __ ]
our Jeff the FBI still has to most
people it still has integrity as a
federal institution Muller Muller that
was a two-year report that was a
two-year [ __ ] I mean are you kidding
look at look at man afford he had a lot
of money manna forts doing seven years
there are people that went to jail who
had a lot of power very close to the
present man for it had a lot of money
from foreign I'm just that's the price
he was not quite the rich and powerful
he was he attached himself to the rich
and powerful in an effort to absolve
himself essentially of his debts and his
sins right and it didn't quite work out
well for him and worked out okay for for
the president so far but we also haven't
seen Muller's report yet we read a four
page that's what um Monica Lewinsky's
tweet was about today it was pretty
funny
hilarious why did she say so someone had
someone tweeted she you know retweeted
someone someone tweeted something about
can you imagine if ken starr's report on
bill the bill clinton investigation
instead of releasing the report they
just his Attorney General put out a four
page summary of it the cleanse
so she imagined if the star report had
been provided only to President
Clinton's Attorney General Janet Reno
who then reddit Florida woman by the way
who then read it privately and published
a four-page letter based on her private
reading stating her conclusion that
President Clinton committed no crimes
Monica Lewinsky retweets with if [ __ ]
you know you know why you know why the
Justice Department doesn't give you the
full report right because a lot of this
stuff is classified information there
and you're compromising FBI sources and
all kinds of stuff so there's a process
there has to be a process here what I
think is interesting is after two years
is no crime there's no collusion no
progeny the 34 people were indicted some
of whom had foreign contacts with with
illicit contact with foreign governments
that they then turn around and lied
about instead of reporting it to the FBI
that hey all these Russians people
reaching out real time yeah they and
some of them are in jail what I'm saying
is is that is unequivocal collusion and
then lying about it yeah some Russian
foreign agent contacts you and says hey
listen we got the goods or we want to
get in with this Trump candidate ur with
you know what you're an American does
you call the [ __ ] FBI and you say for
some reason Russians are up I'm it
doesn't work that way
my dad didn't work business in Russia
forever what happens is this you get a
contract to work for a Russian company
yes and you're making money and all of a
sudden you have conversations but you're
also working for the you're talking to
these Russian contacts you've had and
now you're because they target you and
you're working for the campaign yeah now
if you're working for the campaign and
you're still keeping your business going
that's a crime that can be that can be
under certain circumstances you can draw
all kinds of conclusions so so this
wasn't as cut and dry as it was what I'm
what I'm trying to say is that I don't
believe I never believed from day one
I'm not a I'm not a Trump fan talking
here at all at all you know that but
from day when I was like what are we
really talking about his are we saying
that Russia got Trump elected because
that's hilarious to me that's hilarious
because no they didn't they they didn't
get trop elected the Democrats are the
worst at putting up candidates they suck
the
put up hillary clinton who in 2008 the
country said hey [ __ ] we don't like
her let's put it back up again they're
even flirting with putting her back up
again so i'm sorry but they're so
fractured trump was just a juggernaut he
was a phenomenon he was a guy who was
speaking to a lot of disenfranchised
people bla bla bla
but the russians didn't get [ __ ]
Donald Trump elected he didn't [ __ ]
collude and go get me elected excuse me
come on do you think that I absolutely
believe that as in the case with her
exit you [ __ ] lives in the case with
Briggs it the influence that was exerted
over not necessarily his campaign staff
but via the Russian BOTS and trolls and
and the social media targeting there's
no question that the misinformation that
filtered through the election cycle and
gotten the front of the faces of people
like our racist aunts and uncles who
don't know the difference because
because people because it was racist
when you look at when you look at what
you're saying we're not totally disagree
when you look at the statistics of the
reason Trump got elected because most
Americans have 500 ollars in the bank
did that's what and so this is the guy
that's gonna turn it all around us and
matter that American so you have you
have so this you are they racist which
is it that's terribly condescending cuz
I'll tell you why and act you're a guy
you're a guy who has a family you have
$500 in the bank are under 8 years of
the Obama administration let's not blame
Obama there are thousand forces that go
on with automation and everything else
now 500 bucks in the bank you can't send
your kid to baseball right that's all
you give a [ __ ] about as an American now
now we did vote a black president twice
so all those racist a lot of those
quote-unquote racist or dumb dumbs voted
for Obama now hold on
my life didn't change you got Hillary
Clinton who is Obama who is Obama light
or Obama heavy whatever you want to say
you want me to vote for that guy she
will change you won the popular vote by
an extraordinary large saying is that
who you know who elected this president
a soccer stadium worth of people in
three or four counties in a couple of
slice the electoral college brother
that's right blame the blame the way
we have black people but either way I
certainly do blame the wind you like
people bored I'm saying is as a result
of that you can target people yeah
proper demographics inappropriate in the
vulnerable she was elected the [ __ ]
you gotta put when you have Hillary ran
a shitty campaign in comparison or she's
a shitty candidate how about that and
they're gonna put Elizabeth now rest of
those people I'm sorry I don't disagree
with you that she was not the ideal
candidate I will tell you that what the
Democrats did was totally tone deaf the
counter programmed is what they did
that's my counter program they said
they're gonna put this amateur racist
misogynist con man up we're gonna put
one of the most qualified candidates
objectively if you took that CV the
resume of Donald Trump and Hillary
Clinton you blacked out the names with a
sharpie on top yeah and you just
reviewed the resumes right you go who
would be them and you're hiring someone
for your fortune 500 K so 100 percent so
let's pause there then okay put a pin in
put a pin in that it is just like any
coach that decides to go for it on
fourth down if it works you're a genius
if it fails you get second-guessed
forever that's what the Democrats did
they said we're gonna counter program
with clearly one of the most qualified
Barack Obama was what a second term
senator or first he wasn't totally
unqualified arguably never know that's
just a more academically at all and and
didn't prosecute the back I think if he
had prosecuted some of the bankers who
created the man-made catastrophe that
was the Great Recession I think Hillary
would have had a far greater advantage
but she was also like it wasn't the
Russians didn't get Hillary to put that
email server in her bathroom yeah the
Russians also didn't get James Comey to
immediately put out that letter right on
the eve of the election while Trump was
actually busy paying off his former
mistress he and I were talking no Trump
Trump was you got to keep this in mind
he was [ __ ] entertaining he remember
what he did to the entire Republican
field he fightin we were we already
watch it
the way that that crazy general riding
the bomb and dr. at the end of dr.
Strangelove is a yeah but but I couldn't
believe you got elected I kept saying
I'm on the podcast he was he's never
gonna get on like it's impossible no I
knew he was gonna get elected in fact I
was I was on a podcast with a bunch of
brilliant minds down in Miami Marc
Caputo of Politico Michael Grunwald
formerly of Time magazine now Politico
Fernanda Monte they're having this a
ground table discussion the week before
the election yeah and I'm the only one
who was like I think this something is
gonna happen they all said no chance
some of them said no some of them were
like and then one it was unequivocally
it's it is actually statistically
impossible yeah I thought well wait a
second I'm I mean I'm I'm from Florida
where anything's possible
and we actually and here that here's the
scary thing the Florida of today is the
America of tomorrow so if you want to
know what challenges will face or
calamities will befall us as a nation in
the years to come
don't look I hope the canary in the coal
mine because of the the immigrant the
sort of experience at the melting pot
that it is or Miami doesn't feel like a
like part of America I was just down
there it feels like no it's not they say
the great thing about Miami is it's so
close to the United States I love it I
personally involved [ __ ] I know nobody
lives there just that Alyssa really
don't let thing I love it I can't live
anyplace else I can't I can't live out
here well they do there's some
heartbreak those buildings my friends a
developer down there those buildings
like they sell cocaine money let me now
now it's money long well you got you've
got the Porsche building where you have
an elevator and your car comes up to
your apartment yeah and [ __ ] there's all
kinds of that's for Russians we have a
place a neighborhood called Sunny Isles
which is known as little Moscow and in
Sunny Isles we have these luxurious
condos including the Trump building huh
and what happens here is the Russians
they we have on what the Republicans
would go what you [ __ ] conservatives
would call anchor babies where they
bring pregnant Russian women over who
pay tens of thousands of dollars they
buy real estate they buy condos in the
Trump building they buy condos in Sunny
Isles little Moscow in right just north
of Miami Beach
they come and have their babies here who
are of course now America American
babies those American maker Bailey
Bailey W American you'll never hear any
sing about C's from the president he
never complains about the like Russians
he just looks at them as you know these
babies is future Brides I guess but uh
but the what the [ __ ] were we talking
about
I came 2,000 miles away to call but
you're talking about just a small it guy
how do we get on how do we get the
president we were saying the you think
John is mine
you said Jessie's mother too innocent
and that's and that anybody ever voted
for trama erases no but hang on so I
realized in the state of Florida that we
had elected not once but DOS many our
governor the lead executive of the state
Rick Scott who is is a fact the biggest
Medicare fraud stir in the history of
the United States of America an absolute
unequivocal conman a fraudster who can
who pled the fifth amendment like
seventy five seventy five times in a
videotaped deposition and that the video
was there the state saw it everybody
knows about it to this day
he and they were like it's okay he not
only we're good
he not only was reelected served two
full terms term limited eight years as
governor
he's now a United States Senator for the
state of Florida so I was sitting there
going no the Florida today is the
American from oh we've already elected
our Donald Trump governor of Florida
twice I'll say this is totally totally
gonna happen I was like why why would
anybody think this this is not going to
happen and sure [ __ ] it did and I was
like I stayed up all night you know
watching the results I was like I didn't
watch the whole season of this dumb [ __ ]
reality competition show to not watch
the live results at the my minute to win
it was crazy it was a reality that night
was and then Hillary was gonna concede
and that she didn't can see it I'm like
this is just yeah this is good
television it's just entertaining right
damn the Republic let's well that you're
good TVs let's go back to small the
first thing I got a question because you
you have your finger on this balls does
he work again you know where doesn't
where do you have your finger on Jesse
Smollett I'm sorry
I don't think it worked yet no he
totally works again you think really
well he's give me on Dan starter starter
be on Dancing with the Stars
would you have him on this bucket no why
not I don't think he I don't give a [ __ ]
I don't think he would we talk about I
do not get just you're acting Empire I
don't care you know I'm saying like what
what do you talk about he's not gonna be
real he's obviously a liar isn't coming
and you know what actors don't work on
this on this stage out on podcast they
don't we have actors on before they like
they feel like they have to play a
certain role they're kind of to be
honest they're kind of boring give her
even with one yes many of them it's
about one of her lines from the
producers not actors ever eaten with one
that's just hilarious
I mean it's so worried it's true it's
true dude well I mean you know it's not
like that Martin Sheen he was a date
with Martin Sheen he was really he's
really interesting like he had some
really strong points of view on stuff I
was like damn is what guys was like the
Angie James Woods no he said one time so
there's this movie called guilty by
suspicions about the McCarthy era when
Denis romics I mean actors and writers
and directors and anybody who was
connected being a communist it was a
little bit like it was like it was there
was a woman here this is fifties okay
this was 50 to 53
it was a witch hunt and so if you ever
went to a communist meeting if you had
friends that were communists they
brought you up in front of the committee
for on American Activities forget
communist meeting if you went to a
friend's house yes who was a communist
that was considered some sort of cosmic
Karthi was a senator from Wisconsin and
he was at the quote-unquote
anti-communist and he was gonna root out
communists from Hollywood and from
certain academic institutions but
especially Hollywood so people like
David Merrill who is a great director
and direct like Adam II award-winning or
above nominated and they'd have mother
and David Merrill went to communist
meetings at people's houses and argued
because he was a capitalist and he was
like this is and he got kicked out of
the meetings for arguing but they said
who give us names who were you with name
names that was and he and he said he
said [ __ ] him I'm not doing it and he's
a
thing where he goes have you no decency
sir have you no decency to the to the to
the to Senator McCarthy and so there was
so a lot of a lot of Hollywood writers
directors and actors never worked again
and if you ever see Elia Kazan ways are
they fun to eat with I'm sorry oh no I
was talking about I'm making I'm making
a larger point a larger point I'm making
a lot this is it is that really big part
of it they were blacklisted yeah yeah
and they never worked again and Martin
so I said to Martin she and I go I go
Charlie Sheen's father yeah and I said
West Wing West offenses father yes oh
wow yeah and I was doing that we're
eating and I said we're talking about
guilty by suspicion I said you know you
never know how you're gonna behave in
that situation all it is this was what I
did West Wing [ __ ] 15 years ago I
don't know and I go you never know how
you're gonna behave in that situation
because what they would say is if you
don't give us names just tell us who was
at the meeting you don't even know these
people
yeah but you'll never work again yes
your agent would be like Brennan listen
to me right now yeah [ __ ] you got a
TV show it'll go away if you don't
mention that mom snitch on everyone in
oh yeah that's the thing
are you are yeah and I and Charlie seat
Martin Sheen goes yeah you do yeah you
do and when you behave the right way or
the wrong way
it's a confirmation on who you really
are and I never forgot that I was like
when the pressures on that's who you
[ __ ] let's see who you are wouldn't
want to cost you something whenever I
think about Martin Sheen I think about
do you ever see hard hearts of darkness
of filmmakers apocalypse the documentary
that I just think about him losing it in
that mirror break he had a heart attack
in the middle of a scene like he drank
so much like this is the best actor
we've ever seen dude he drank so much
James Woods can't be he had to be a he
was a special forces guy who had to go
back into the jungle in Vietnam and he
had to he literally had put up bring up
the opening scene of Apocalypse Now he
had to [ __ ] they they had to have him
going crazy like going crazy Salma
Brando I'm talking about Martin Sheen
and Brando is every discourage that's
who he was going is that so Martin Sheen
in the in thing he he starts drinking
and doing I think blow and he was doing
some pills anyway long story short he
was our heart attack after he's done a
heart attack
yes they will this
him doing it's a wit it's - Jim Jim or
seven minutes
Jim yeah but either way either way he's
the guy losing his mind and and he lost
his mom
yeah losses mileages is so so so brando
gets there the great Marlon Brando and
he's too fat and he doesn't want them to
shoot him from these four no light right
yes I gotta want to see how bad I am
and then he swallowed a bug in the
middle of his thing he didn't know his
lines he was all [ __ ] up man all
[ __ ] up this is the same it'd be tough
not to do drugs if that was the kind of
a role so I felt on election night yeah
it's just kind of out of it
that's much Charlie Sheen's dad I mean
dude man I wanted to point the biggest
[ __ ] movie star I guess I keep
forgetting you're 36 yeah that's how old
we are
he's older to me yeah real he's but he's
still doing it though oh no I'm thinking
I'm Michael Douglas's dad did you see
him at the Oscars nineteen I'm a hundred
years old
yeah Kirk Douglas fir Douglas is Kurt
Douglas theater you know he's a wrestler
I think it was a like a high level
wrestler - in college no well yeah not
now no not only still doin Russell Kurt
Douglas was they put up bringing your
lead picture of him in Spartacus bring
up wheelchairs in the rear the ramps he
was the he was one of the original
Hollywood tough guys look at him yeah
yeah yeah and like what are the early
like actor moguls you know add like his
own production company yeah I'm like
multi-picture deal David look at that
divid miss ya in Culver City there's the
the Kurt Douglas theater there right
yeah he built it with his bare goddamn
hands sucking looks like just Richard
[ __ ] there is now yeah I said my grandma
okay father look how long you know what
father time is like we're gonna he and
he's had his face pulled by a great run
the whole last a great run we're the
best
I woke up Hall of Fame the other day and
I couldn't move I must apologize in my
shoulder 40 and hole someone said well
what'd you do I was like I woke up just
what if it'll stop like I didn't I
didn't lift a half gallon of milk or
anything I
just woke out in time like oh you must
have slept funny I was like no when I
see why those baseball players do all
that [ __ ] I would think about you might
be only athlete I've ever met
pro athlete who just doesn't have any
injuries it's kind of crazy like it
lengthen you you don't have any issues
with your knees no because I left knee
gets a little when I was in San
Francisco with Tariq one guy from the
Detroit Lions and another guy from who's
about to go play pro they were just
enormous men and what these were they
were 22 23 and they're yeah coming off a
nice of weddings well I've had both my
shoulders we've done he's I got two ACLs
I got I was like I mean they're there
they're literally Humpty Dumpty but
they're huge
are they huge I'm not that big these
guys are huge you're pretty big like
Great Danes have issues I'm not that
compared to those guys you know I'm not
great you don't play football for twenty
twenty year with ten years at least yeah
okay well you've fought in UFC I mean
you'd think you'd have song I'm not that
big like you if you if I'm around other
UFC heavyweights
I'm not big right but around a football
players now how does that keep you from
being injured cuz I threw like Great
Danes at Great Danes oats have [ __ ]
hip dysplasia you know I just think the
big bodies break down but you hit a lot
it's a strain it's a strain of the
weight is a strain of every the body of
the mast absolutely yeah it does though
no because it does big guys always break
first yes always absolutely white light
like it's 40 to 60 but your your big guy
but now but I'm big to you in the in pro
sports I'm not big I'm big to you as an
actor right in pro sports I am NOT a but
that wasn't what I would think that if
you're a bigger you'd have more padding
and you could take an hour but you don't
have knee issues or anything as what I'm
trying to say no it's it's just rain
it's the strain of all the cheering all
waiting and that height getting hit well
that doesn't help right but that's why
Rob Gronkowski who retired you and I
think most people should know this no
[ __ ] man the guys had all those injuries
he's kind of done at all I need as young
he's just like yeah I'm out man like
Mike my boy clapping Stein the main
reason he retired he was a first pick in
the second round to the st. Louis Rams
and then he just kept getting injured it
was like I'm so sick of being hurt wait
I remember after a game in Detroit Lions
we went to go see him play his first
touchdown catch and he we have to help
him walk up the stairs after that and I
was like Jesus Christ I know I'm a guy
in Miami you can help him out help ma'am
yeah give me protocol but you've been
around enough athletes you know I've
been athlete where when I see the stuff
with HGH and them going these clinics I
give here dude if people only had us
hint of what those guys go through
everyone else would do it as well
everyone everyone does like you know a
lot of mostly people to go to the ant
these anti-aging 200 are not
professional athletes they're just lay
people who feel good and they want to
reverse the ravages of time they're
learning yes I mean that's the good
things about the cell the cell
stem cells are like yeah of course what
constitutes a performance-enhancing drug
everything caffeine's are
performance-enhancing drugs and feta
means adderall there's a
disproportionate number of players that
get waivers to be on adderall I say
disproportionate I mean to the general
population why the sign in baseball
you've got 162 games and 180 days it's
the most grueling grueling schedule and
professional sports that's why I see
them phone it in sometimes because like
you can't play it's honestly it's like
when you're when you perform for a
living if you're a Broadway I got
friends on Broadway I'm like I don't
know how you sing your heart out and
dance your heart out eight you know
eight eight times a week they go we
don't know you gotta cheat it you got I
just a laborer who just came out well it
came in since I was a kid
I've been touring I've been on the road
I'm gonna take a break from music
everyone is what the [ __ ] is that
towards last year towards the end of my
tour I was not giving you guys another
percent I was checked out yeah and if
but in people that's [ __ ] man you
got it easy like don't that poor kid you
remember you haven't you know when we do
the road you're on the road three days
four days you're like you can't wait to
come home
can't wait Taylor Swift was on the road
for 365 days basically it was performing
she was traveling terrible I don't know
how you do that I don't know I really
don't know you do that I would go
[ __ ] crazy might go crazy crazy but
up but also you can see why people lean
in towards supplements or peds so
especially in baseball hockey football I
mean Kelly is only 16 games so you
but like the rest of the sport you can
see like or active comedians thank you
out on the road oh my did I get it when
I was in cow gonna add whatever 990
[ __ ] shows by the end of that last one
I was losing my voice I'm like dude it's
on had cocaine right now I would snort
all that up just to go at this ground
and nineteen twenties Yankees Mickey
Mantle whitey bulger Billy Martin they
used to party at the Copacabana all
night long have to be up for one o'clock
game maybe a doubleheader they were
doing greenies yeah they were doing an
ode you gotta somehow make you don't
have a problem with it you know you know
I don't know that I do either the MLB
realized that about in the 90s that
could they'd have all these people who
study everything they found guys who
weighed less than 165 first of all you
don't hit as far but also the other main
reason was that they wanted bigger guys
because they broke down for whatever
reason when your body is a certain size
like 165 170 and you're doing that over
a number they didn't hold up as well as
the guys who had an who are a natural
tournament of [ __ ] baseball monsters
that they created that as steroids yeah
McGwire and Sammy Sosa yeah it was so
fun and they needed it they needed it
cuz the players strike in 94 everybody
thought that baseball would never
rebound the other popularity yeah and
they needed these baseball monsters
smacking balls to Guantanamo Bay like
they're now just but now they they just
they're the black ball those guys yeah I
know it's listen baseball is like
everything else in in America and and in
politics it's the WWE now okay so the
storyline in 2013 was Bud Selig is
getting ready to the Commissioner
baseball's getting ready to retire he is
the steroid commissioner okay everybody
knows it he knowingly exploited and
profited from these monsters like he's
just these dudes who literally we morph
them in the movie from like their
original body weight when they were
rookies to through the way to like
Canseco and Mark McGwire and you know so
it's ridiculous so everybody knew what
was happening nobody cared it was good
it was good television so baseball they
needed Alex to be the heel that's that
was the storyline that made sense Seeley
goes to a second command Rob Manfred
says this scandal just broke please look
like make it look like I did something
about this yeah and so what
scalp could be bigger than the
highest-paid baseball player of all time
Alex Rodriguez
so they went after Alex Rodriguez both
sides spent millions of dollars broke
laws ok went head to head in this battle
of the legacies a Bud Selig versus Alex
Rodriguez they bust him
yeah they reduced his his suspension but
we still like the longest in history it
was an entire season by the time the
smoke cleared and then Selig retires
goes off into the sunset robbed man for
the second in command who ran this whole
ridiculous
botched investigation which includes
quintessential Florida [ __ ] he
becomes the Commissioner of Major League
Baseball and he goes okay what's the
storyline now if you're Vince McMahon
you know the best storyline is when the
heel becomes the hero yeah so now what
is UT Utley brings in for crying out
loud
not only a rod but Charlie hustle Petros
himself to be commentators on Fox and
and then they were brilliant they're
good they're sure not so good and that's
a little crazy he like goes almost
tasted banned from baseball again as I
turned that second time he's gone they
they fire happen he's crazy
is sensation he's the best they have
he's so he's so awesome anyway I never
said good New Yorkers love to hate him
because they don't I say he chokes
during the playoffs and they'd be like
[ __ ] you know with his blue lips and
all the guys phenomenal he's just he's
um see him in person whose kid was 64
230 handsome machine I told you when I
saw him in Vegas I was I think I was
with roguery that strip steak house in
Vegas yeah and there's a whole table of
us and a rods there with two girls you
singing up times there were two girls at
the bar and I got a rose my favor love
a-rod and I like [ __ ] there's a rod and
the guys at the table top they go ah man
[ __ ] that guy I mean what the [ __ ] would
you but see what are you talk what do
you mean [ __ ] that guy but you know what
he's done for this guy that amazes you
kidding me this one the best baseball
players to ever live he's an interesting
character respect like firfer that skill
set he's in jail oh you [ __ ] he's also
he's also like if his teammates like him
like he's also well liked his name
he hasn't done his research that's
what's so that's that's what's so
compelling about his second act right
now that he was always despised hated
and so it's a me it's like so this is
what that jealousy wasn't that just sort
of like yeah he was weird dude yes it is
your child might get along let me tell
you it's it's it's something every man
he's in so your mentor Justin Bieber I
think there's this theory so it in
recovery in the role of recovery they
say that your emotional growth is
stunted at the age you start using so
the 12 year old kid that goes into mom's
medicine cabinet and starts you know
self-medicating pills you're you can get
older but you're always like an
emotionally stunted I think that's true
of super famous people like Justin
Bieber Fame when you get the [ __ ]
famous and that rich you are emotionally
stunted that age why people stop telling
you no people stop telling you the truth
well I know yeah well you get lied to we
are who we are from our failures telling
us know from people setting boundaries
yeah you don't have boundaries you're
Michael Jackson you're you're Michael
Jackson you're [ __ ] crazy
yeah hurt you're emotionally stunted at
the age you became that famous and that
rich you can't if you can't walk outside
to buy a pack of gum hmm that's too
famous do about Michael Jackson he had
to rent out supermarkets hire actors so
he could pretend he was shopping to feel
like a normal person
yes you don't think you're me [ __ ]
Alex Alex is that famous and that rich
and I think and so he's like I met him
he pitched us this documentary in
November of 2013 that's why I'm here
that's why we did this Wow yes his ideas
his idea and I met him right in the
thick of the arbitration with MLG smart
dude man right in the thick of the
arbitration story broke in early 2013 in
the Miami New Times biogenesis steroid
scandal right and Alex was the only one
of the players caught up in it who
appealed his suspension I guess he
figured it had nothing to lose he got
the biggest you know suspension and so
he decides
I'm gonna go after it so they go to
arbitration everybody else gave up
everybody else even Ryan Braun who lost
his goddamn mind for a while in that
whole skin left he just Lambie peed he's
like let me take my lumps and then dip
and you know got paid though yeah he
went he went crazy for a minute blame
like the tester for being anti-semitic
that was a problem it wasn't him under
the buddy was ugly huh Alex as it turns
out it's in the documentary
Alex threw him under the bus Alex's camp
leaked other names like Ryan Braun after
the initial story came out to Yahoo in
order to like take some of the focus off
of Alex in it Alec his whole team was
they were they were it was [ __ ] they
were warm they were ruthless dude he
hard-boiled Roy black the biggest
criminal defense attorney in Miami he
got a PR team he hired private
investigators there was money on the
streets this was a holy mother [ __ ]
fought back oh he fought back
oh this was this was OJ this was oj
versus the the nobody's fighting fair
though he's like you would go that to
those extreme absolutely lied to
everybody about everything always that's
what he did when we met he's just lied
uh-uh
Alexes yeah yeah but who could blame
them I mean I'm a documentarian lied and
lied about his use of PD at this stage
in his career not lied about knowing
Toni Bosch the fake doctor who was who
worked with Manny Ramirez and all these
guys has anyone really came out and
admitted like did you see the the 3430
on ESPN with Sammy Sosa
no I haven't seen have you seen the
interview they do the sit-down and I
have a little control who's interviewing
them he goes I can't [ __ ] stand like
that but he sits down with Sammy Sosa
and they're like friends and he's in his
home and he goes so Sammy you know
obviously you've done lotion to your
face and you know he's like kind of like
poking them and he goes but you've done
steroids you mean we can go us and
Sammy's like ah he's like trying not to
answer and he's like yeah I've never
failed a steroid I've never failed a
test all I know is I've never failed
test and the guy keeps going look come
on we all know Juventus I've never
failed a [ __ ] test man so would he
would he only say he's like yeah but
you've done peds and he's like I have in
his horrible you know brokenness you I
have never failed a test like what do
you want me to run from me and they get
anyways I'm sorry gotta stop that's like
walks off
becuse I don't know I thought we were
friends I don't know he disrespect his
his skin hit this whole weird thing with
his skin is the strangest thing I've
ever seen in my life
how do you get yourself to be that color
it's like a mood ring I think you like
now he has a different slightly
different pigmentation but like none of
those guys because the tainted legacy
none of them really say they've actually
done it right Billy like has anyone had
them like Barry Bonds McGwire no no
one's really taken responsibility Alex
himself has never really done the maiya
culpa tour you know like he's never
really guys you that's not though so you
did all the research they found doctors
they found the guys who were giving the
steroids out who then named names does
that one no it was or how kind of us
here's the thing this story is not
actually about Alex Rodriguez it's not
about him don't tell him that
but it's not about him the story is this
Carl Hiaasen Elmore Leonard Cohen
brothers esque tale of Florida [ __ ]
this botched heist movie it's here's the
thing the career of the highest-paid
baseball player in history effectively
ended over a $4,000 debt between a
cocaine-addicted fake doctor and his
faked an addicted steroid patient and
okay a rod and all these they were
collateral damage this in this battle
over $4,000 four weeks time this guy
snapped said [ __ ] this guy this and this
whistleblower stole the documents from
Tony Bosch's little like like office
park storefront office on us one right
across from Alex Rodriguez field the
guy's secretly administering all these
PS so Tony Bosch was the founder of
biogenesis and a series of other shady
gray market clinics so the anti-aging
business exploded in Florida like in the
in the zeros yes and appropriately so
the mythology is that Ponce de Leon the
Spanish explorer discovered Florida on
the search for the Fountain of Youth
correct and so oh whatever I'm doing
that is work it out it's we're not just
some I am as like what the [ __ ] is that
yeah it is amazing it's a spring break
his remake valve not a flatus be found
late until amazing so what's bosch doing
then then now he's off cocaine for 5
years so that's good that's a good start
has he got money he was in oh he was in
a like he was hitting rock bottom at the
time this scandal erupted I went to
federal prison for two years in no small
part and deservedly so because he
administered some of this [ __ ] to kids
high school high school the parents and
coaches brought their kids to him to
give them an advantage in the draft it's
not surprising them not surprising it
also hyper-competitive I mean really
yeah no forget college they do dig it
drafted right during high school 17
years old the minors and yeah absolutely
so they're looking for every advantage
in and there's not they're smuggling
rings that smuggle kids from Cuba and
South America to the United States in
order to pursue their baseball dreams
geez yes the American dream is to uh get
smuggled the United what are you gonna
do college football well I did the you
you know the you part - I feel like I
feel like you mean like NC double-a [ __ ]
I mean like this the sketchiest yet not
didn't really didn't really prepare for
this people I can't wait to watch he
started this interview with like you say
Stu okay you got your his documentary
now he'll pitch document pod zoo grew
ball and your services so you get too
much he small a to embarrass myself more
where does this come where do we see
screwball screwball opens Friday March
29th that's this Friday
well baseball's opening day is Thursday
March 28th so screwball opens in select
theaters twelve cities on Friday March
29th and next Friday April 5th on the
VOD machine so iTunes Amazon
pay-per-view where you can anyone demand
it has a rut seen this I don't know he
and JLo are welcome to any screening
they want free of charge Rob Manfred s
to pay for a ticket no mixes but they're
welcome any screening I don't expect to
get a wedding invitation but they're
they're welcome to so it's not as
flattering to a rod
well the problem is it's the truth yeah
yeah that's sighs so it's not flattering
by the way to anybody right nor should
it be though that if you just know you
could do this documentary and paint them
and a good what you're the subject you
the whole thing was a [ __ ] and
everybody acted like children that's why
we have children playing all the it's
all acted with through children all the
it's all trees in the trailer should we
show you the trailer
I've I'd see the true social I might add
my resume good where's my IMDB doesn't
really do the truth is I didn't know you
were gonna be on the podcast until this
morning
surprise do you know that prize a movie
booked at six weeks early yeah I did not
know so no I was never meet your heroes
because they'll break your heart
from the moment I remember I wanted to
be a baseball player it was the American
dream
I got kicked off the team for smoking
weed I was a disaster my plan was go
into medicine medicine medical and
performing it was a perfect place for
the anti aging movement especially down
here in Miami every wants things now now
now it's almost no regulations you have
people who pretended to be doctors given
all types of medical advice he had a
white lab coat that said dr. Tony Bosch
he had a stethoscope around his neck
yeah I assumed he was a doctor yeah you
would he wasn't a dr. Cuddy client
within weeks he's focused what's much
better he felt a lot quicker
this guy says yeah my cousin's in the
Yankees it was a a rub he says I want
whatever man he was taking I had a true
believer right away you know seven days
after he started my program he went
ahead in one game he had three whole
months and he said I'll give you an
extra hundred fifty grand a year if you
give me exclusivity I said for 200 you
got a deal listen he'll run cost money
at this time biogenesis had close to 300
athletes we were consuming so much
product I had to go to the black market
okay I just stumbled across some kind of
steroid wing and think I was gonna get
caught I was busy going to party cocaine
bill was $6,000 a month biggest steroid
scandal in sports history
explosion dollars look if I don't get my
money I'll blow this whole thing up put
a bit what a [ __ ] get rid of steroids
now this is my whole life my legacy you
tell me why I should serve one inning
Tony Bosh is not a doctor Tony Bosh is a
drug dealer coke addict bad son bad
father bad brother bad everything what
can you tell us about that no comment
he's lucky he's not in the canal
anywhere
this guy's connected a lot of people
involved don't do this you're gonna get
killed so I got my nine-millimeter
that guy's a very sleazy thing Major
League Baseball did and trying to pay
witnesses threatening people to
cooperate hey rod and his crew we're
doing almost the exact same thing he
pretty much can forget the Hall of Fame
it was almost like hey mom I made it to
the big leagues but in a different way
you know you can't make this
that's incredible dude that's blood it's
it's wild I can't wait I cannot wait
I've Bosh seems like he's what's he is
he Italian when it was he to mix Cuban
Cuban yeah it's a he's he's got a his
last name is is actually no relation to
Chris Bosh Miami Heat but his last name
is has holds a lot of sway on the
streets of Miami in the Cuban exile
community his dad's cousin Orlando Bosh
was one of the most famous anti-castro
Cuban exile terrorists in history among
his on his resume he stood on the
causeway connecting the city of Miami
and Miami Beach right by the Port of
Miami where all the cruise ships are and
he had a bazooka on his shoulder this in
the late 70s and he fired a missile at a
Polish freighter because come o nice to
come own ISTA and fortunately it didn't
arm as it fired
he just hit the side of the freighter
and rolled into the water Christ Jesus
time for that oh hell yeah yeah but he's
a hero in the Miami oh well you know
Cuban exile community so it's just it's
that kind of story like that's that's
little tidbits like that and you know
and then of course a bunch of kids
running around facial hair and lab coats
and the devil it's also important I
can't like super creative the way you
did it
here's what's hilarious to me too is so
we know all this stuff about Bosh we
know about you know the this stuff with
the NFL and the dude in northern Cali
what's his name the guy who got battle
coke I'll bet all that but if people
think that the peds and all that stuff
isn't going on right now there's another
serve yeah there's there's gonna be a
whole nother thing about this and people
say yo like in Miami like who's the new
Tony Bosh like in Miami like where do
you go I like neutral I said it's really
easy to figure out you drive around
South Miami Little Havana Hialeah
suburbs of miami-dade and you look in
like office parks strip malls you find
like a nondescript place where it says
like clinic on the outside of it and
like a mirrored or tinted window and a
bunch of cop cars from different police
to
Apartments parked in front of it and
that's why the cop cars cuz their watch
Joanie but no their clients
Tony Bosch had a hundred pull cop
clients massages but yeah I gotta get
off the [ __ ] about Robert Kraft
Florida shadows a party
Jupiter yeah Jupiter the salary can beat
yeah broke up you can jack off sorry
we'll just him going in they come out
like three minutes later that's quick
yeah you mean that nine-year-old
billionaires been ejected by Thomas come
here huh but also just be cool man let
him do that agree with the promise I
think there's the Patriots are always
draining balls hey man you're a bit of a
[ __ ] whistleblower me talkin
subversive you're not really so much
this does the whistle blow and then he's
like you know what that's good story
yeah there's a lot of whistleblowing but
enough about Rob have you thought about
doing like what as you learn more I mean
I there's so much pressure on me from
people because I'm 52 or they're like
get on T RT man what the [ __ ] are you
doing I'm always like alright guess I
could yeah you feel like I said to my
doctor I said what about loss he goes
how do you feel I go good because yeah
okay there's no I use Mashable that's
into frame you know it is yeah you have
absolutely
I told you this good I just love your
stand-up you have the most physical
stand-up show that I've like ever
yeah I get tired imagine that on
steroids though that's how you sell a
[ __ ] roof with a shovel of the air
that's called a rod you hit 30 home runs
imagine you unsterile right the way I
look at this I have to take I have to
shoot two stops front of my ass and then
I have to take an estrogen inhibitor
maybe and then you got to get your blood
checked every three month at Sal OTT of
[ __ ] I think I might just get old then
you wouldn't mind being [ __ ] jack
dude do it right then you're one of
those like weird harvey levin like older
dudes who's like jacked and then people
look at you like the same people who
told you to get on under like what did
you do it why do you look like they so
we're busting out of your clothes
even button your dad it's awkward yeah
I'm shaving my chest help ya it's so
awful yeah you when old guys get like
that song you're painting yourself
grandpa orange like Hulk okay you know I
do want to get my I'm gonna have my eyes
lifted and I'm gonna look great right
here to do that [ __ ] what's the next
story Billy Billy where do you go from
here yeah the clinic with Kalin money
for you she and Stan Arachne yeah work
at de-spawn Jupiter and see what's going
on yeah what is your next project do you
have any ideas right yeah we we just
actually finished a doc that we've
premiered at the Miami Film Festival at
the same time we did this one called
magic city hustle and this is about the
strip club get it that's is it no it's
not but that but that would be that I
should one of them what are we sitting
around here for so it's about get this
so former University of Miami athletes
got an email from the athletic
department saying if you are not doing
anything because a lot of former
athletes don't have a lot going on
they're going to be tryouts for Magic
City casino to play highligh play what
highligh yeah you don't know highlight
no well you're not prepared for this
interview what do you have to do not
bring up highlight you got this game is
crazy
it's a Spanish game from the Basque
region of Spain with a base like
handball with a curved wooden basket
better dangerous ready better yeah the
ball goes like 150 miles an hour
super 8 they called the world's fastest
sport what years is they sent that email
but last year
oh wow so here's the thing and we
followed them for the first season
here's the thing in Spain this is like
baseball or football or said like jeez
well the kids grow what they're born
with baskets like corrective in India
right much here these guys have never
heard of it some of these guys got the
email spell j ai al AI hai lie
so some guys are like what is jalawla
I'm gonna go play look jalawla
yeah and they're like no do you know how
to announce it that's fair although they
were I'm sorry to interrupt
recruiting them to play the game because
they're free Catholics out of - oh I see
they never played this game before
there's husband with an athletic ability
really hard get they these guys suck
dude they start a January February of
2018 training and then they on July 1st
ready or not they were professional
highlight players and at that they were
the worst highlight players in the world
imagine but it was like but also skills
in the history of the game there's only
been like three African American players
in the history of the game these guys
came in it was like Cool Runnings or
something it was like this really
charming almost like it even harder
League slap shot like kind of like
underdog story and we followed them
around for the whole first year and
gives here's the thing did they make any
money he's gonna make money it's like a
behind of my talk gambling yeah athletes
made much might be called it magic city
hustle cuz dog gamble it's all gambling
it's a gambling sport yeah it's a they
don't give a [ __ ] that they're not very
good now they have a lot of pride though
as former hurricanes you know like that
swag remember Kenny Kelly quarterback
and and and professional baseball player
- nard Davis here Oscar yeah and but
here's the thing being in shape like
that does has nothing to do with your
ability it's a steel set it's just
practice yeah it's muscle memory which
one of these guys makin so they were
making some first they had a salary big
salary but here's the thing that got
health care some of these guys any
health care no no these guys are driving
ice cream trucks some of them are
driving uber one of them zakat this guy
was a cop in Georgia um and like so the
it's called Magic City house was in
Miami you know you've heard of the gig
economy and we call it the hustle
economy and nobody has one job I mean
your side hustles have side hustles in
Miami they just released a study of the
United Way a few weeks ago 60 percent
that's 6-0 60 percent of Miami Dade
County residents cannot afford to make
ends meet basic needs and forty percent
of those are the working poor so they
have at least one at least one job and
they can't afford just to live in the
county that's a lot of the country and
that's why that's why I was saying when
Trump get something goes to its gay
back jobs that's why the Miami of today
is the America of tomorrow and every
single every single plant and
manufacturing location he promised he'd
save has basically closed since he
campaigned in front of it and and
literally exploited those poor people
but elves working how's your document
how's this end these guys just stick
with it
they love well we follow the money full
season we just followed them for a full
season and someone listened some of them
get a little better not that they
competed can compete against like legit
guys who've been playing there or
professionals who've been playing their
whole lives but listen they got a base
salary they got medical and dental
insurance and then every game they
played eight games a day how long's
again from Wednesday to Sunday
that was like fifteen hundred games they
played from July 1 to Thanksgiving so my
friend who's now unfortunately did have
a brain tumor but not in Frank but my
friend me and dubs friend he was a car
he was a mathematician and he and his
three friends you score out of
Connecticut and they and you know that
and they would go down and they would
they would use their math to basically
win and highlight I don't know how they
did it do you know how they would do
that let me tell you then the mob came
up and said and he said to me he goes
this guy came up and he was smiling and
goes so hey listen you're gonna have to
find another place because they know
itself yeah and the county cards and
they and and but he goes and finally he
goes I don't understand what you're
saying do you not want us to play here
and he goes you're not welcome here
anymore and they're like oh [ __ ] ok no
problem thanks a lot man you get thrown
out of Connecticut you know you fight
alright but how would they how would
being a mathematician allow you to only
pretend to understand this cuz I really
[ __ ] up on this project I spent five
months watching highlight and didn't
learn how to bet on it some of the guys
at my crew did and they one of the maids
like two or three hundred bucks just on
a two dollar bet it's so you you bet
like trifectas and numbers and and you
can and here it is notorious this sport
has a reputation for being notoriously
corrupt yeah and Miami Vice has a whole
episode about X it was huge in the 80s
the sport and so these guys are not good
enough to be able to be corrupt if you
like to cheat at it so you actually the
gamblers love this because like they
said oh they're so bad
there's like transparency here they can
see them practice and they go oh this
guy is ok this guy's awesome I can't
[ __ ] catch this guy
so there's if you know how to do it you
can make money doing it I have no idea
how how they did it I really like these
guys and and some of them I mean it
literally opens with one of them driving
up ice cream truck through Liberty City
was the neighborhood that moonlight took
place in with a an uzi for protection
and and ends with him doing pretty doing
pretty good that's cool I mean it's it
is cool I hope for them I don't know if
they love it but at least it's a you
know means to an end I guess dude in
five months some of the main six figures
in five months so between the 1500 games
so for every game these eight games
every game like the guy who came in
number one got like 125 let's say bonus
second guy got seventy five third guy
got fifty fourth guy got 25 so just in
accumulating those plate just placing
one through four you're getting a little
money then at the end of the season they
gave out bonuses for whoever had the
most wins you know first second and
third and singles for a second and
doubled in this league in America I've
never seen oh it's it's it's just it's
called Magic City casino it's by the
airport it's a locals casino it's like
all away no si Abuelita 60 70 80 year
old Cuban folks just from the
neighborhood Little Havana and B they
found the goat dude it's dude they they
have salsa live salsa band every Friday
and Saturday they're shaking their cool
owes their area I'm coming down to Miami
in May to do visit us yeah Key Lime Pie
on me alright thank you absolutely
you're the new improv then you knew
Miami Doral great yeah it's great is it
direct words were so news we call it
derails whele right up all that if I
stayed in Brickell and you up all the
way in felt brick I stayed four seasons
rich now so I stay at the four seasons
then would drive to brick why didn't
they put you up at the Trump Doral
that's right there well they well they
won't because you can stay there there's
a hotel over there yeah cuz Darrell's
way west how's the trumped around it's
white I don't know how's everything way
west I don't pay sure it's right by the
airport basically it's you have to Jason
to the deploy only took us like 20
minutes
Oh
depending on the time of day Brickel
yeah depending on the time of day it's
not at all certain times a day it's it's
rough but flown into Miami during the
day you probably only flown at night you
see Trump's name in big letters that's
montréal is golf courses right there
just south of the Stanley yeah you and
Jimmy woods can do the back nine nice
look at that Trump now you go let's see
if they'll put you up over there how'd
you get good deals on Trump places right
yeah cause nobody's generally staying
there yes what I wouldn't give a [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] that house for [ __ ] half
price a lot of times doesn't even know
his own his name those buildings he
doesn't know there's a hotel in uh in
New York that I used to stay in all the
time the Lower East Side the Kushner
brothers just bought it I will not stay
there anymore
I don't care how she's no the rates are
one to that Trump's son-in-law well the
man in charge of our you know foreign
policy a Middle Eastern policy he'll
bring me this guy he'll bring peace all
right well ma'am how do you think he got
into school ask Aunt Becky yeah she adds
a criminal who donated millions of
dollars to Harvard I think Don junior
got a camera his SAT score Don studied
how do you think dr. Joe's daughter
sound remember uh documentary drops this
week Friday yeah March 29th I the day
after opening day of MLB MLB and then
and then you know what happened a couple
weeks ago the distributor Greenwich
Entertainment they just released free so
low that won the Oscar yeah documentary
great document yeah so they they they
drop our trailer a couple weeks ago
started to pick up steam people like
this is funny sharing it building
building some buzz the next day
Instagram a rod is on one knee putting a
ring on J Lo's finger I wanted the text
a rods publicist and go well-played dude
well well-played bro hit so I would just
ask the other day someone said hey do
you think this is legit this thing's
this like a PR thing with JLo and I've
no reason to believe that but the like
oh you think they're ever gonna get
married I said our movie comes out on
Friday March 29th they'll get married on
Saturday March 30th if history is any I
love it man would be willing get it
where again oh yeah well 12 cities you
know New York LA I think Chicago Miami
Boston
nor Lando because Florida and then VOD
next Friday Friday iTunes on the works
paper view yeah appreciate to mom man
anytime thanks for that great stuff
brother thanks see you in Miami
can't wait yes sir well there it is
Billy Corbin close call by cocaine
cowboy find stuff I love Billy he's
great it's [ __ ] great always
interesting does it make a bad
documentary this that's right I'm gonna
give my dates now do that well sign out
Philadelphia one show still has tickets
that's Late Show Thursday check it out
Calgary sold out adding a show Thursday
Late Show Denver April 25 26 27 still
tickets left Comedy Works downtown all
tickets at e5k DeNiro Miami Miami with
Billy 9 Billy 10 and 11 what is that
place called juice to Miami improv Miami
improv mate any place
yeah 9 10 don't you see Brian tickets ah
this week I'm in DC all shows sold out
20 tickets left on Thursday though
Thursday's the only one not sold out
Phoenix we are almost sold out as well
Phoenix end of April 26 to the 27th get
teeth now t fat K calm for tickets
complicated Apes still out there
were you renting by it's still doing
well thank you to everybody
complicated apes boom my special this is
the five kid route